the end is now
oh it's a little quiet here alexian put
in some music
some scare sorry scary music
scarier good that's good that's good
okay welcome to hamer i don't know if
i'm gonna hit someone with a hammer
a hammer or if that guy is gonna hit me
with a hammer
is this just quiet is this just no sound
close that five lives left what
five live left for what why my mouse
here
there we go okay is this like grandma
hey grandma oh i can't get in the closet
grandma
a hammer is that another language for
grandma grandma
i lock grandma grandma
loud drawers well i guess i wait for
death
to approach me me on a blade
hello oh god why am i down here why
would i be here
why can't i see my body okay cool thank
you
there were no instructions by the way
blank okay what is the craftsman
[Music]
what it's c but oh god hello
you hit me with a hammer
why'd you hit me with hamer
so it is like grandma so you are a
okay i would like to get out now
right cue it is exactly grandma
huh i did not know that well
you mess with the wrong guy you're not
my grandma so i won't take it easy on
you
okay i'm looking up what what
you think you can get me by being slow
like that
no go away yeah it's bad place to be
you will never find me never ever in a
million years will you
find me okay i guess i'm
free to go
hammer those shoes on the other foot
[ __ ] let's go
it's hammer time let's do this yeah try
me
what does this do what's this for
oh yeah a hammer that makes sense hammer
that
hammer the lock hit it hit it hard
enough oh
hey bud how you doing
all right see what's in the freezer
nothing
what's in here nothing let me hide in
here
oh [ __ ] did he see that oh no he didn't
see he saw that he
definitely he's definitely coming right
for me okay you
uh close the door and uh
idiot idiot you idiot you fool you stop
you stop don't yeah you
fool you idiot you bamboozled you
kneepad wearing [ __ ] that's what i
thought
and you got a flat ass too you are
an idiot i'm gonna find this key there's
actually uh
i think did that summon him
[Music]
oh well there i go then my legs and my
head
a little bit redonkulous if you ask me
but okay whatever
ow i did it again
am i gonna recover or am i just like
this forever now i think i might be like
this forever now
okay let me just get these down here
oh yeah oh yeah
just gonna stand up there we go i'm good
oh screwdriver
oh okay you know what this is why you
have treasure chests everywhere
hey bud i'm gonna screw no hey stop e
do that that's what i thought
you're too afraid of me i am a terror in
the night and you are just my pawn you
are my play thing
i screw with your life like i drive
these like i screwed
this use the screwdrivers
driver idiot
okay can i is this a thing it is not a
thing
well that was all the that was all the
things i thought of
well time to die is there anything else
am i crazy there must have been
something else right oh
the medical box you better not be right
around the corner
[ __ ] [ __ ] no really oh come on oh
maybe
oh i gotta go for the actual screws yeah
yeah yeah that's what i thought oh
yes i'm out of here [ __ ] get out of my
or get on my life
get out of my life i'm gone i escape
i did it i escaped
fireworks i like that it was a very
simplistic
grandma kind of game i like that that
was good
could have been a bit spookier but that
was good i did like that okay
moving on this is pyrolyzes
i don't know what pyrolysis means but
lixian will provide the definition right
here
hope you read that oh um what oh
huh hold tab at any time to view the
control okay
all right i play i will play
oh as usual i find myself in an
apartment
or a house either way my home it was a
busy day today
i should put away my coat in the closet
because i'm a neat freak like that
who does that oh terrifying closet
jacket is that a firefighter why
why would you do that why would you do
that to me
you bastard nicole oh
now now hold on
one moment here i'm
i'm you know i'm not a i'm not a
i'm not a fool but uh
[Music]
my phone hello
why didn't you hear the news
there's a serial killer on the loose
we're all in trouble
yeah i think i am a firefighter of sorts
if my jacket's gone also it is different
room
it's not the same room different did i
have a cactus in the last room i don't
know
hello you bastard oh boy
time to kick up the feet and bam
splat out kaboom wow that's a
fun channel
[Music]
now most recently gaining more attention
the tragic death of marcus wyatt
father of two young girls and a boy this
happened just last night presumably
after midnight
since text messages show he was still
alive by then police say due to the
secluded setting of an alleyway on the
corner of pyro street
there was a long period of time before
the death was reported the incident is
currently under investigation and the
suspect has not yet been found
police say wyatt suffered what seems to
be a lethal axe strike to the chest
more on this tonight stay tuned am i
happy
am i wyatt and me wyatt doesn't seem to
worry
oh fire i have no use for this right now
but as a firefighter i'm always prepared
okay i'll go over here now oh
how did i guess that this would work
this is different
different different wow key or
kex singe mel
yeah i like the heat as well it's
usually this time of year i love to go
out to the beach
yeah i wish we could even go out to the
beach though what with the circumstances
and all
i don't even remember the last time i
relaxed outdoors
speaking of heat did you hear about that
old warehouse burning down last week
i think so isn't that an abandoned
warehouse not too far away from pyro
street
yeah it is i don't think it was that
abandoned after all
three people were reported dead inside
the warehouse after police arrived
wow that's so sad i wonder what made it
catch on fire
yeah i wonder oh i wonder oh
okay oh
well
all right pills huh i shouldn't take
them again so soon maybe i should
maybe i should just log a few down
i'll be going now
see ya oh
i thought that was open from when i last
left it opened oh my god was there
something in there lixie and replay that
what the hell did i see beam it into my
brain ah thank you
hello ah you're actually real
the undulating corpse oh hey you left
some art let's just step on your body
here
we're always here you can cycle between
items by pressing q
i sure can
paralysis pyrolyzes
parabolas stop being you
stop this stop this right now
oh
there was a key inside i don't
understand that hello i don't
it's crunch crunch smash crunch
behind you i don't believe i i believe
you now
hello
ow you [ __ ] hey
wait a minute what oh
well hey listen hey this is more what i
was
thinking about but you can you can stop
the approach there you can
oh what an intricate design you have in
your mask there
hi hello oh yeah don't like that
i know that game i know that face boom
i played that paralysis
oh
i don't know what i'm doing uh sir are
you okay
you need a key are you all right how did
this
happen at all ever i need to get out of
here
do i i'll take that thank you
shall i administer cp oh my god
oh my god how is there that much blood
in you
hello who needs a chopping
ah what is it though okay it is
but is it though yes it is
i can walk through now hi hi yeah
how are you oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh ow what the hell return to
change the channel
i hate the oh what
what what
what why secrets six or seven what do
you mean six or seven six
ah that was a secret was that a secret
was that another secret
no don't do this to me bad ending bad
you're a bad ending
no i'm going back in there's apparently
secrets so yeah i didn't use that key
that's right i didn't use that key what
does that key go to that's the thing
that's got to be the thing
that's going to be the thing
damn it it's something to do with using
the key
but how oh
what what so something written on the
skull what is this
let the weight of your sins rest on your
soul we will never let you go
we will never forget okay still
six of seven huh there's something else
here there's something else
going on here
maybe i just die in the fire maybe
that's what i gotta do maybe i just
gotta die
oh seven of sev oh hi um
wow you are creepy bear you are
terrifying you're not doing so good
um oh hello
oh yeah that's a good picture just
because you're here don't think it's
over
you know i wasn't thinking it we won't
stop just as you didn't
just as i did am i the axe murderer we
will be with you
okay forever oh okay so i just needed to
go through it again and with
by finding that skull i think i have no
idea either way
that was great i love that it was kind
of a one-and-done kind of thing which
most of these games are that like how
much
work can you put in to give infinite
replayability into these things but a
really cool experience for what it was
i enjoyed that very much pyrolysis from
the makers of
paralysis very good very good
moving on all right so this is a weird
one
this is called a possum country it's a
scary game that's
made for game boy so i'm assuming it's
going to be
super ultra retro not even like
playstation retro that some
uh a lot of horror games have been
lately but this is like going
so much farther back damn i have no idea
who ordered this
so i'm a pizza delivery guy food and no
reception to check
only homes i see are these trailers i'll
just have to knock on doors until i
figure out who ordered food
hey anyone hungry is that not possum
oh my god it's it's legit
game boy rules all right whatever
hey jesus christ
i know nothing about no food move
quickly around these parts you hear we
don't take kindly to strangers
why why don't you take kindly to
strangers
and if you see bill you best stay on his
good side boy
okay what are we wrong with you
what's wrong with you what's wrong with
you
excuse me did you order any food
i'll take that means no sorry to bother
you
okay bye
why don't you take kindly to strangers
oh smells good but i didn't call for
none
you see my wife she ran off with someone
for all i know
could be you okay why would you think
that in this incredible circumstance
that the person that your wife ran off
with would come
back to deliver you food bill told me
just believe and i'll see her again
okay all right who's bill who's
bill who is bill you best get my pride
okay
food ain't mine but i can bet whose is
bill's the only one who can afford that
stuff
now scram all right so no one ordered
food
something was up with that quiet girl i
should check on her again before i go
should i is that my job here yeah i
guess you know
that's probably a good idea
a young girl here
we're known to collect lost sola too why
why are you known for that why would
anybody be known for that
whoever brings back a sinner from wonder
wandering will
save his soul from death says who but
i'm the only one living in this trailer
you have a good night now now i know
something is going on
i better ask everyone else if they know
anything about that girl
i'm concerned for her safety you know to
be perfectly honest
i would huh there she is
i'm glad i found you come with me you
won't have to eat out of the dumpster
ever again
follow me i'm parked down here okay
come on come on come along get in let's
get the hell out of here
all right let's go huh the car won't
start well that's inconvenient
damn now i have to see if one of these
creeps has a phone
oh you again fetch me some water from
the well and i'll tell you all about
this here village
[Music]
well the well use my phone why i suppose
so if
it'll get you to leave us alone oh
chainsaw i guess it's useful in a rural
area
it's dead i really don't like this
we're waiting to join our brethren in
rebirth don't interfere
what excuse you pardon me
excuse us pardon we didn't i tell you to
get lost bill keeps his place from
free from trash like you without him
we'd all be dead by now
we're just waiting for what's next stick
around and you'll see
okay it's an old pump well can't believe
they still use this thing
i need a container to get the water
of course i do can't think of any reason
to suffer in that creepy forest
of course i don't i'll stay away from
this guy
all right says you um
oh no what the hell happened to my car
she's gone how the hell
do you rip a door off the frame
how does something like that happen
they go to the woods behind the trailer
park well no water for the old lady
maybe only oh hi friend
who left this in the middle of the woods
i found a bottle yeah
[Music]
well that's the most heeby gb inducing
thing i've seen in a while
my brother roy came here and disappeared
no one won't tell me nothing
i want to check out the woods but uh-huh
i need some way to break the lock
if i had a gun i could just shoot it so
am i just like
short or something or are you is this
normal for you
they grow them big in the woods i guess
all right i got a bottle i can get some
water i'm gonna fill the bottle
all right i'm gonna go to the lady maybe
get that chainsaw from that dude i don't
know
about time you brought me some water
this is what i need for
these oldies
ah now it's more comfortable to talk oh
look at that smile
what do you want to know about the town
who is bill
bill is our leader he knows how to heal
us
we live outside of society already he
has a great method for helping us escape
our worldly form it's in the shape
of a long barreled pool it'll help you
escape the worldly form all right
real quick too never see it coming
uh what's happening it's hard for an
outsider to grasp it might sound strange
but it's easiest if you think of us as
wild forest creatures on the inside bill
just helps us shed our skin so
we can assume our true farm
ah hey god brought your gun
no one's answering the door try the door
it's unlocked
ah she passed out drunk
yoink all right well got this
am i gonna need this chainsaw later
maybe i can use this in the wood i stole
that hey did you mind that
all right cool see you around buddy you
don't mind
mine now [ __ ] hey tall guy how you
doing that gun looks like a piece of
junk
are you sure you know how to use it
press and hold the b button to reload
[Music]
i'm using z only holds two bullets so
i'd avoid the blossoms if i was you
all right now shoot that lock
maybe watch where you put that you've
never touched a firearm before have you
the lock is over to your right
i'm sorry for trying that i'm sorry guys
apologizing
all right uh reload how do i how do i
reload
watch out for the possums all right you
got oh god oh
god i'm watching
oh well there's a lot of them there's no
book it says number 487
remember laura age 23 escaped him an
abusive partner
keeps present secret from outsiders
transformation compatibility level high
oh what one of the best candidates i've
seen
bill okay this should do the trick
i probably should have gotten this
afterwards but
all right uh well
oh god oh god it's a battle oh no
reload bam bam got it
did i get it i got oh god more
okay well this is it is clunky as hell
but it works i guess all right you're
all dead or you're
the ones dead and it took four tries
[Music]
oh well hey i don't know why this is so
unsettling for a game boy advance game
looks like it's converted into a church
i mean it just goes to show that it's
never about what's actually happening
it's about how immersed you can get
there's a notebook that says 473 new
member
jed followed wife here after her
transformation
needs constant assurance transformation
compatibility level low
not sure how to handle this one bill
okay looks like they can play vinyls
here
it's an old radio crimin doesn't work
i'll get to you in a second buddy
don't think i'm ignoring you well i'm
trying to i'm trying to forget that you
exist
it's a notebook 479 roy wife and child
died in drunk driving accident had a
falling out with his family over money
transformation compatibility level high
transformation complete
where's roy what does transformation
mean
did you look in the back room i'll go
look so you don't have to
oh you're this oh you're the same dude
ah you're the same dude an old camera
i'm kind of glad there's no tape inside
yeah me too buddy yeah me too
there's a notebook 480. bethany suffers
from loneliness
wants to find a new community
transformation compatibility level
medium nice woman reminds me of mother
okay
42. tammy suffers from alcoholism and
paranoia prone to confrontation
compatibility medium a real handful yeah
i learned that myself
oh no what the hell yeah you know
uh yeah shed skin i didn't take that
literally
oh i think i'm gonna puke uh yeah my
dude um
where's roy did you look in the back
room take it from me you don't want to
see what's back there
we need to get the hell out of here no
sign of the girl maybe i should head
back to the trailer park
all right i'm out of here buddy sorry
about roy uh but he's
oh god no not no oh
god reload oh i'm okay all right
oh hi there you are i was worried about
you
oh never mind oh never mind
oh yeah never mind you're busy i can see
that
sorry for bothering you you have a
lovely day now
we'll catch you on the flippity flip see
on the other side ah
goodbye oh jesus christ
okay no
what's wrong with you outsiders can you
do anything but fear others oh you're
gonna turn this on me
oh you're gonna make this a moral moral
situation where i'm in the wrong
all we wanted to do is be left alone and
people like you come here and steal from
us
is when we're being reborn to a life
free from the complexity of human
society
oh don't you turn this around on me you
come here to murder us
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know i don't really know you know i
don't really know man i don't know
now that i think now that i am thinking
about it now that i
think about it uh you know i'm not
really uh
not really sure why what's wrong with me
i love that i really like that that was
very good the twist at the end
what was i supposed to do let it kill me
wow
damn that was cool going retro even
before retro
was a thing i don't even think there
were horror game boy games
i don't even think that was a genre but
it should have been it would have sold
well that was actually kind of spooky
i loved it i really loved it
hmm is
[Music]
you